all right get a free thanksgiving turkey
just for just for taking a test drive at
philly toyota jc fernandez visited john
barr for the details
on this spectacular promotion take a
[Music]
look
hi i need some crayons and some
construction paper
[Music]
sharpie and paper that'll work thank you
this would be a good turkey gobble
gobble this is the turkey that's going
to get me a test drive
here at findlay toyota jc what are you
doing hey
john uh uh well i really want to test
drive a forerunner
but i don't have a turkey so i was
hoping that maybe a hand turkey would do
but a hand turkey but we give you the
turkey
oh that's even better i thought so
i thought so can you take me outside and
show me some of these cars let's go
outside let's go you want this now
sure why not alright so john this is a
great promotion come down here
test drive a car and you're giving your
customers a turkey how's it all playing
out how many turkeys we giving away
we have 150 turkeys and all you have to
do is actually come to findlay toyota
and test drive a car
you will get a turkey that easy we
talking new cars used cars does it
matter
it's going to be on new cars all right
new car sales that's the way we're going
to do it but i mean
150 turkeys that's a lot of opportunity
and i believe everybody hopefully will
leave with the turkey and be very happy
and maybe a new car you never know yeah
that'd be the perfect thanksgiving a
free turkey and a nice car from finley
toyota
let's talk about the safety protocols we
have our mask on
the stuff you haven't played here well
we have obviously in place
social distancing in the mass the
primary things that the government asks
for
we make an attempt to obviously comply
in those rules as much as we can
we have sanitation hand sanitizers and
all the things inside
and we are always cognitive of social
distancing our showroom is really big
so it enables us to hold 250 people
under the protocol of distancing so it's
a good thing yeah now
what is this car right here what are we
looking at right here this is the brand
new venza
brand new 2021 venza only comes in
hybrid yeah it's a hybrid so how many
miles are
someone getting with this hybrid edition
generally you're looking at 500 to 600
miles per tank
wow incredible that's huge yes the one i
wanted to test drive is the 4runner and
this one is
gorgeous back here it's a beautiful car
popular popular been
one of the staples of toyota for so many
many years
this is something you can you can go
places you can go anywhere in this thing
right
anywhere anywhere great ground clearance
great reputation
been with us for 30 years plus
yeah it's a beautiful truck and and i
want to take it for a test drive so i
think i just need some keys
they're all yours all right let's go
thank you john i'll be back in a few
minutes you bet
[Music]
this is great john i love it you like it
yeah it's a great test drive
good well here's your turkey you broke
the car
it's that easy that's right easy turkey
thanks john it's that easy happy
thanksgiving buddy
you too you want to find a couple hours
a couple hours all right
findlay toyota's turkeys for test drives
it's happening this saturday november
21st from 10
a.m to 7 p.m so just give them a call
702-789-1627 or find them online
at findlaytoyota.com